[Applause]
[Music]
see told you you'd be glad you came
[Music]
no business like show business I know
you hate it and you love it but thank
you so much for coming you run our
anniversary show now you're on this show
I couldn't get you for 25 years now
you're on twice in three weeks I I love
the trend and you sound awesome on the
song you sound as good as you ever have
[Applause]
there's a new Barbra Streisand there's a
great day in my house I love this one I
have all the old ones I'm gonna get the
next one and all the new ones that are
gonna come out but this one you know
it's a great and that's such a catchy
tune - okay you know I'm glad you have
your old your old crew I see in the
credits back there Carole Bayer Sager
and yes wonderful team yeah um I was not
gonna say what about no no it's just
interesting you know real life real life
and real sadness as well as anger I must
say what motivated me it's amazing that
you can take something I mean the name
of the album are the walls but the idea
the first song what's on my mind you say
right in the beginning I wanted so on my
mind Trump is on my mind you channeled
it into this
I couldn't sleep nights and so I was
thinking oh my god now they the
photographs in my head the pictures you
know the children being ripped out of
the arms of their parents
I remember you know about the one of the
last lines in that song is what ever
happened to just being kind
still they're still there so yeah but I
think I think we share something which
is we both hate liars mm-hmm you know
you can do almost anything to me or say
it's right just don't lie to me
I know it's it said don't lie to as a
child that's why I'm so passionate about
lies and people who lie by family I was
that I was sent away to a summer camp
and I my brother came to to visit me I I
said you're not leaving without me
I always had a strong will you know and
I got a cart and I remember and packed
my things up and she had to take me home
and in the car was this stranger this
new man no and I I thought who is this
and he turned out to be my stepfather
but I was never told about that and that
way my mother was gonna have another
baby
nothing was ever told to me you know
when I said to my mother
why did well that was later but I said
why didn't you ever talk to me about my
father my father was a teacher a scholar
and a religious man by the way and she
said well I thought you'd miss him
but you see you see what I mean by yeah
the lying by the way as an actress or a
singer what you depend upon is truth
truth communicates lies reads you know
in this case I mean is lies see no work
for a bit but truth eventually wins out
don't you think
well people it reads
[Applause]
the audience or people who are voting
for a politician they very often don't
know the specifics but they kind of
sense whether you're for real I mean not
everybody even in my own audience agrees
with me on stuff but the bond is that
they they know I'm never pulling a punch
I'm always being straight with them and
you know when it when you're like that
you can be friends with the other side
you are friends with Republican I mean I
you Bob Dole called you recently right
you that's right when I went to singing
he's 95 years old and sounds totally
there plausible and gentle and kind
I keep using that word but it's very
meaningful to me but yeah he wanted to
give me a compliment it was just very
sweet and taut we talked about working
across the aisle and how much he was
able to do with george mitchell when he
was the george mitchell was the
Democrats of course but Bob Dole was the
leader of the Senate and that's the way
it works did you see furries fareed
zakaria with Madeleine Albright and :
Powell
no I mean they're dear friends they were
both secretaries of state for different
kinds of residents and yet same people
can agree to disagree
either very civil conversation I think
part of the problem is that politics is
too much in our life when I was a kid
mm-hmm it was like something that was
almost impolite to talk about you didn't
talk about religion or politics the
neighbors we didn't know what they where
they went to worship or who they voted
for you just didn't go there and I think
that's our way back to sanity
people say you got to talk to the other
side but then what they really means you
got to convince them you're never gonna
convince them know you've got but just
don't don't talk about that [ __ ] talk
about you know everything else that
people used to talk interesting is that
when like as an actor you have to
inhabit other people's personas right
you play that role but
in order to play them you have to
understand them and and that takes away
a lot of bigotry I think if you really
step into other people's shoes right and
empathy empathy reason why the right I
mean they fear you but they go to your
concerts you know I mean you they do
well I was fascinated one one place I
don't remember I think was in Washington
DC I asked how many people in the
audience are Republicans and a lot of
people raised their hands and I said
sure you're the ones who could afford
these tickets of course
biggest art cuts through it that's right
don't transcend it really does it does
music but one reason I think they are
always you know against you is because
you have been effective I member in 1986
yo they're against yes they're very much
against you they don't like you remember
years ago when I was supporting
something or me and control I was on
Nixon's enemies list that's right which
I was very proud to be understood
[Applause]
I was kind of gratified when I found out
this week I was on the Bombers list you
know I mean you don't want to be left
out more scary and it's a lot of more
scary well it's all scary but yeah but
you know in 1986 you remember you did
that concert for the tree and it was
about the Senate was very much and yes
we Democrats kind of pulled it out I
mean we be money yeah five out of our
six senators yeah and they won and the
the Senate was able to flip from
Republican to Democrat yeah so that was
very powerful Williams was my opening
act and then Barry Gibb came out and
said do it oh it was a good evening you
know I love Barry Gibb he said about you
there are the 10 greatest singers in the
world and then there's Barbara Streisand
[Music]
[Applause]
but so how do you balance I think we all
fight this how do we balance like not
being obsessed with Donald Trump
thinking about him all day because I've
never known a president who was more in
our heads which is sort of what the
album is exactly what I do is first of
all engage I eat a lot do you eat and
I'll eat sweets like coffee ice cream
right that that counterbalances the
bitterness that he's wearing a toast
and also I have to play games literally
before I go to sleep I mean to get him
out of my head to get the news that I
watch all out of my head thinking about
tomorrow I have to be in the present to
be in the present you have to play gin
you know you have to play rummy cube
right you have to play scramble that's
my way what do you do
I just turn I find I'm watching in
season basketball I've never done that
oh yeah I've always waited to the
playoffs came around and now it's like
those things well it's just as just as
opposed to watching the news I mean I
can't watch the news although that's
right you have to do it off it's um I'm
just what's going on with the
environment Oh Mike I mean that's you
know that's like the Forgotten issue
because of all the sudden he's mentioned
about the younger people and I read an
article the other day that talked about
18 to 29 year olds one-third of them are
not going to vote and I think but what
do you mean just think about climate
change what's gonna happen to your
future your children's future this is a
terrible problem the Republicans and
this administration have wiped off all
of the information about planet truth
the truth yeah that's climate they don't
even want to know what yeah it's one
thing to make the argument it's another
thing to not let the people hear what
the truth is right so there's no
transparency it wasn't there with his
tax returns you know didn't people think
what is he hiding
I mean why change the norm right see
above the law why is he abusing this
power he has those people who say you
should live with those conflicts of
interest why do they let the other
Republicans let him get away with it
well yes
that's a great question they're at lien
aviators where are the George Bush's of
yesteryear those people you talk about
the Bob Dole state we are so appreciate
your yes well well we have it in
perspective yes and and I will be the
first to say me a couple maybe I was too
hard on him but now that I see what it
could be
oh wait I didn't finish my thought
before I can fight when I sang in Texas
I invited the bushes to come see the
concert senior senior yeah Barbara Bush
right and they were so lovely and came
backstage at first and I gave them a
gift and they gave brought me a gift and
invited them to you know invited me to
their house and so forth so lovely and I
introduced them to the audience and they
got a standing ovation and I thought you
know he served our country she stood up
for women and you know that's our common
ground that's for the common good it's
for decency and and you know people
getting along well never stop speaking
those people are say shut up and sing do
both sing one question yes why do we
allow the media to keep showing him on
TV why are we covering these rallies is
that 70 because there's no because
there's money in it because the media
used to be a lost leader they didn't
care if from covering the news made
money and now it has to report to the
stock room like everybody else right
exactly
Thank You Barbara
[Applause]